Keith I'm hearing the word product come
up a lot and I love it I love that you
are thinking of a film as a product it's
not just a project it's not just
something you've created a work of art
whatever where are you getting this
because I'm thinking of a product
sometimes as a piece of code someone's
written they've turned it into an app
whatever but you're you're seeing a film
as a product right well essentially so a
film it's a piece art it is it's a piece
of art that's also a product in a sense
that this is a business and you most
people if you make a short film usually
that's because you usually short films
don't make money or they don't get
distribution they're not really meant
for that so that's not really something
you sell but when you get to the feature
film world that's it's like going for
maybe like college football to NFL
you're going up step up a ladder to
where it's so time-consuming and it's so
much money involved that you're then
once you still upset ladder you're kind
of stepping up to the plate and telling
the issue like hey I'm ready to you know
I'd like making films or whatever it is
I'm passionate about this I'm also here
to sell you know I want to sell films
till because making a feature film
that's usually there are piece art but
also it's a product and a sense of this
is all business you're there to sell as
well as make the film so that's
something what's the way I see it's a
business overall that's really what it
comes down to and you know if you're
passionate about it and that's something
you enjoy doing it's a piece of art it's
also something that I see is also I want
to sell it tool you know and getting to
have it people see it not just make it
over a two-year period you know or it
long it takes does anyone ever
challenged you over that like oh man
keep calling your film a product you
just call it a film but I mean not
really but I think it's just no not
really I just think it's it's you can go
make like if like I said if you just
want to make a piece of art and just see
it only
is just that then go ahead and make you
know your short films so that's less
time dancing but once you're making a
feature it's like that's a toy different
animal you're spending every waking
moment of your life on that thing that
seems like at least for me as how was
your waking moment with life energy
sacrificing friendships I mean time
friends and family and um yeah you
stepped up to that plate to where this
is your passion about this but also you
want to start selling your films and
make it a business it's really what it
comes down to when you start making
features so when you're in that level in
that category and you stepped up to hey
ah my feature film director
you're also a business man that's
essentially what you are if you're doing
short films you're not as you know
that's like say you just do that for fun
I think and you can try to sell those -
yes but the future films really what
distributors people buy into and they'll
start selling and stuff so at that point
then at that point you're there to sell
something which you're passionate about
you know
also a piece of art but it's a product
in that sense so calling it a product
doesn't sounds like in your mind doesn't
diminish the fact that it's creative and
that you you put your you know ideas and
these different maybe fantasies in your
head or whatever but it also means that
there's money on the line and there's
accountability with it correct
and I equate it till most like say an
engineer makes something it takes him
two years three years to make it well
sure as an engineer wherever he's doing
in that field like he's passionate about
what he likes to do he might even see it
as like some type of like art or
whatever he's something that he loves to
do right but also he's there to make
this thing and he's there to sell it to
at that point so I kind of see as that
like the engineers taking this products
or taking this piece of work and we're
building it up and then they're putting
out in the market so that's kind of the
way I see it in a certain sense as well
but you're passionate about it too and
it is a piece of art but it's also this
on top of that a product something to
sell
we're like an inventor from my past
invention okay it's like making anything
technically and then selling it so I'm
taking years to make it but you're
passionate about it obviously he would
spend years making something unless you
really enjoyed it
you